foreign
[Applause]
navigation is an exciting new feature
which allows one person to lay down a
trail of virtual waypoints someone can
then follow the route later on by
following the audio cues you can think
of this like laying down a trail of
breadcrumbs and following them later on
first of all let's switch to the world
channel channel short text World preview
if you're using a device with a lidar
you'll have buttons for filters and
actions and you'll find indoor
navigation inside the actions menu
actions
indoor navigation
on other devices you'll see indoor
navigation right on the main screen here
we have a list of all routes found
nearby
as we swipe through routes heading we
hear there's just one route break room
to coffee bar button break room to
coffee bar so let's double tap it and
select follow great alert follow button
loading root
now we hear a sound coming from the
first Waypoint and Visually a series of
balls stretching out along the Route
let's walk towards the sound
and that pop indicates we've hit the
first Waypoint
let's look with the camera left and
right and we can hear the location of
the next Waypoint let's keep going
there's another one
and another and let's keep going
that success sound indicates we've
reached our destination
and here we are at the coffee bar
that's a really quick overview of
following a route with indoor navigation
this is really early technology and we
invite all feedback from the community
we want to know how you use this and how
we can make it better